you j'espère que vous allez bien
j'espère que vous avez tous passé un
très bon été moi ça va vous avez
sûrement vu la vidéo sur le népal est un
moment genre dans les dix premiers jours
quand j'étais non avec les méditants et
tout est une pensée qui m'a traversé
l'esprit c'était pourquoi je resterais
pas avec eux dans son rythme de vie un
petit peu monastique coupé de tout
pourquoi pas quoi il ya deux choses la
première c'est parce que mes proches ma
famille mes amis enfin les gens que je
vois je les apprécie et j'ai envie de
continuer à les voir la seconde c'est
que je quitte ma vie en société et c'est
notamment grâce à youtube grâce à ce que
je fais sur youtube c'est à dire en gros
faire des vidéos ou pas je vous partage
des choses et vous vous les recevez et
je trouve ça génial quoi je trouve ça
cool parce que hein ça me plaît de le
faire et 2 c'est utile et 3
potentiellement bas je pourrais vivre de
ça et ça serait vraiment top et je me
suis dit assez de chance folle de
pouvoir faire ce genre de trucs et
pourtant pourtant attendions montre
pourtant depuis le début de l'année tu
as sorti jordi vidéo genre une vidéo par
mois avec la mise au point n'est pas
tout à fait fait avec un seul coup de
fil un seul à ascq tu as fait ça en dix
mois quoi cc c'est dommage en fait c'est
juste dommage quoi donc en fait
j'aimerais produire plus mais en même
temps c'est hors de question que je
fasse un truc qu'ils soient moins bien
que je fasse un truc qu'ils soient
bâclées que je fasse un truc qui ne
plaisent pas donc du coup vu que ça a
l'air compliqué d'augmenter la fréquence
de production sans changer le niveau
j'ai pas trop solution soit pas vrai en
fait ce que je
cette année c'est ça c'est que je
produire beaucoup plus je produire
beaucoup plus donc je vous en parle
avant parce que ben si je produis pour
personne ça n'a aucun intérêt le but
c'est que vous ça vous plaise aussi que
ça continue à vous plaire et que qui fit
le truc et que s'il ya des trucs que
vous n'avez pas à vous maintenant prête
pas et qu' on converse là dessus etc
j'ai réussi à me libérer du temps je
réussis à m'entourer sur certains trucs
c'est hyper cool après a priori c'est
hyper cool et je vais aussi échanger des
trucs au niveau des formats alors je
vous explique aujourd'hui il ya quatre
formations ma chaîne tiendrait il manque
une vidéo que j'ai pas mis dans ce
format là il ya les coups de fil aux
quais que connaissent et surtout il ya
pop up ou je prends un truc de la pop
culture et j'en parle de manière
philosophique il ya seriously où je
parle de news d'ailleurs il en manque un
aussi et y à ascq où je réponds aux
questions que vous vous m'envoyez
d'accord ça c'est les quatre formats
principaux de match n
ces quatre formats ils vont être ils
vont continuer à exister et ils vont
être au rythme de un par semaine
sire que tous les jeudis à 18 heures il
va y avoir un format que javascript et
ça c'est des formes action script et ses
accès format qui sont écrits à l'avancé
qui sont travaillés où il ya des
recherches et est donc tous les jeudis à
18 heures il y aura soit un coup de fil
soit 1 à ce qu'ils soient un pop up soit
un service lit sachant qu'il y en a un
de chaque chaque mois d'accord en plus
de ça maintenant il va y avoir des
formats qui sont non scriptée alors les
permanences culte et c'est par exemple
un blog alors pas comme ce que j'ai pu
faire au népal parce que ça va être
compliqué de faire ça toutes les deux
semaines
tu as également les blogs se seraient
toutes les deux semaines mais ça peut
être des trucs sur le développement
perso je vois où la page ou au micro des
trucs sur le développement perso je vois
des trucs que moi j'apprends que moi je
comprends et que je vous partage et là
du coup j'ai pas besoin vraiment de
scripts parce que ça sort directement de
la nombre
l'autre truc l'autre forme assez
informant que j'ai besoin de vous c'est
un format qu'en fait on va écrire
ensemble
l'idée c'est que je vous pose une
question et vous vous y répondez vous
donner des pistes de réflexion à ça et
moi je partage vos pistes
je les lis gelé commente on se marre
avec et c'est possible avec un autre
youtuber vous donne un exemple ça est
plus simple je vous dire tu imagines si
demain on est tous immortel qu'est-ce
qui se passerait qu'est-ce qui se
passerait concrètement dans notre
société
ok je vais donner un exemple ce qui
pourrait se passer c'est que comprendra
plus de médicaments du coup tout ce qui
est pharmaceutique l'industrie
pharmaceutique va se casser la figure
et du coup va ya voir graphe du chômage
dans ces secteurs là sauf que ils ont
telle compétence du coup ils vont
essayer de se réinsérer dans tel truc
n'en sais rien tu jamais donc c'est
assez précis hockey et là j'ai choisi
une piste j'aurais pu en choisir juste
il y en a des milliers
il ya une infinité quasiment et donc
l'idée c'est que vous vous essayez de
trouver des trucs et faites vous plaisir
genre ça peut être aussi des trucs un
peu marrant d'esprit un peu drôle et ça
peut être aussi des trucs hyper
recherché genre vraiment allez-y vous
fait vachement conférence là dessus à
chaque fois je vais solliciter vous avez
su produire de très belles choses donc
et pas de problème donc du coup je vous
balance est un thème pour la prochaine
pour le prochain t'imagines si qui
normalement que je vais faire
normalement et les eaux de la chaîne
darty biologie si vous connaissez pas je
vous mets en destruction semaine
prochaine allez-y kouchame comme ce que
kool shen sarah perdant donc la question
c'est t'imagines sinon je vais la lire
bien pour être choqués pas de quiproquo
s'imagine s'il n'y avait plus d'hommes
plus de femmes mais que tous les êtres
humains et aide un troisième sexe un
sexe unique ok donc ça c'est la question
que vous pose est balancé dans les
commentaires du coup toutes les pistes
de réflexion qui a qu'à autour forcément
c'est une question qui est assez courte
du coup il est possible que vous
demandiez ouais mais ces genres d'un
coup on devient
on passe à 7 heures d'un coup ou cet
état a toujours existé franchement à
vous de voir
vous mettez les présupposés que vous
voulez ou autour de la question parce
que ce qui est intéressant c'est aussi
de voir comment la question peut être
interprété qu'est ce qui va changer
suivant les présupposés cette question
là et c'est alors c'est vraiment ça
dépend de vous ça dépend de ce sur quoi
vous avez envie de réfléchir en fait
donc je pense que ça peut être un super
concept ça peut être très cool ça peut
être très drôle l'idée donc c'est lui de
faire une semaine sur deux alterner avec
les blogs et tout ça ce serait le
dimanche
d'accord donc le jeudi 18 heures on a
une vidéo script et le dimanche il y
aura ces vidéos là qui sont un peu plus
des tentes voilà c'était vraiment le
plus important c'était vraiment ce que
je voulais vous dire je vais pas
m'éterniser exemple de blog par exemple
dans deux semaines je fais un ted x à
valenciennes donc si vous ne suivez sur
facebook vous l'avez sûrement vu
eh ben ça peut être un super blog de bas
c'est comment ça se passe derrière intel
x fois là je crois que j'ai tout dit ça
me fait graver plaisent de vous annoncer
tout ça on se retrouve donc jeudi 18
heures ça sera un coup de fil ça fait
bien longtemps bien longtemps qu'il
avait écouté sa sueur schopenhauer et
j'espère j'espère vraiment qu'il vous
plaira namasté